le 6 et le 13 décembre prochain il y
aura les élections régionales il faut
absolument se mobiliser et il faut dire
à chacun qu'il n'y aura pas d'alternance
il n'y aura pas de victoire nationale en
s'il n'ya pas d'abord une victoire une
reconquête territoriales pour ces
régionales qui nous sommes dans la
dernière ligne droite de la mobilisation
pour les élections régionales
vous qui êtes comme moi quotidiennement
sur le terrain vous savez que ces
échéances seront déterminantes pour nos
territoires mais aussi pour notre pays
et régions c'est les lycées l'université
si l'apprentissage c'est le
développement est connu c'est la
formation professionnelle des chômeurs
ce sont donc des leviers très important
pour ramener la croissance dans notre
pays et aussi pour ramener l'emploi est
très important que les 6 et 13 décembre
prochains dans la grande région nord pas
calais picardie nous mobilisions dès le
premier tour pour être premier au
premier tour la liste que conduisait les
bertrand avec nos amis de lydie du modem
les chasseurs les agriculteurs des chefs
d'entreprise artisans va se mobiliser
pour que cette grande région qui est
désormais la troisième de france en
terme de population puisse connaître
enfin la voie de la croissance et
d'économie avec et xavier bertrand alors
on compte sur vous les 6 et 13 décembre
prochain n'oubliez pas d'aller voter
pour les élections régionales pour notre
grande région aquitaine limousin poitou
charentes
l'emploi sera au coeur de notre
édification l'apprentissage les
infrastructures numériques les
infrastructures routières ferroviaires
portuaires aéroportuaires
tout ça sous tend l'emploi de demain
dans notre région de rhône alpes
auvergne
la gauche se divise nous nous sommes
unis le président actuel été élu pour la
première fois en 1978 nous nous
apportons des candidats du
renouvellement
alors aidez nous apporter un nouveau
souffle sur rhône alpes auvergne et
chansons sont blessés
il invite à venir à voter très nombreux
dès le 6 décembre prochain pour marc le
fur
marc le fur est notre candidat en région
bretagne
il a fait l'union de la droite et du
centre il affiche surtout le choix de la
bretagne et ils vous invitent à tourner
la page de 11 ans de socialisme dans
notre région bretagne les 6 et 13
décembre prochains languedoc-roussillon
midi-pyrénées
il ne s'agit pas seulement de voter pour
désigner les conseillers régionaux est
voté on sait que c'est très important
il s'agit cette fois de voter pour
fonder d'une nouvelle région je demande
solennellement mais avec beaucoup de
confiance à tous les républicains de
corse de voter à le 6 décembre prochain
pour la liste conduite par josé rossi
sur laquelle je figure parce que assez
de cette date là de ce 6 décembre que la
reconquête du pays à partir à voter pour
josé rossi voter les républicains les
élections régionales sont un enjeu
important pour notre région
c'est une région la normandie région
historique à qui a besoin d'une vision
d'ampleur qui a besoin d'une vision
d'avenir faire de cette normandie une
région où il fait bon vivre une région
où l'emploi deviendra une priorité
demain la normandie sera une grande
région une belle région et
nous serons tous prêts pour pouvoir
redonner un sens à cette grande
normandie conquérante dans notre région
centre val de loire il est indispensable
que nous soyons tous devaient tous
rassemblés autour de la grande famille
des des républicains autour de nos
partenaires centristes pour offrir une
expérience et une alternance aux
quelques 3 millions d'habitants de notre
région et la bourgogne franche comté
mérite une grande mobilisation pour
l'alternance pour redonner de l'espoir
quand je suis persuadé qu'en région nous
pouvons faire beaucoup mieux qu'au
niveau national et notamment pour
l'emploi pour nos entreprises pour
l'emploi des jeunes
alors vraiment je compte sur chacun
d'entre vous pour nos valeurs pour aussi
redressés d'abord la région et puis
demain la france
il faut vraiment que partout les bonnes
volontés se lève pour aller convaincre
la mobilisation de tous est nécessaire
pour aller se battre pour ces régions
pour que la réalité démocratique puisse
se traduire dans la gouvernance de ces
grands territoires de ces grandes
régions que notre pays puisse une
nouvelle fois se construire et croire en
l'avenir en donnant des chances en
particulier à notre jeunesse pour
qu'elle sache qu'aujourd'hui tout
pension à elle et nous pensons et donner
toutes les chances de pouvoir s'épanouir
travailler et vivre dans notre beau pays
la france pour faire de ces régions un
vrai contre-pouvoir à la politique du
gouvernement
et parce que les régionales seront la
dernière élection avant la
présidentielle il faut se mobiliser
il faut aller voter le 6 décembre dans
nos régions c'est le rendez vous du
nouveau souffle grâce à vous je vous le
promets le 13 décembre prochain
ça va changer